hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his article the ethical significance
of cost-benefit analysis in business and
the professions Robert Audi is going to
first consider utilitarianism which is
you know heavily dependent on
cost-benefit analysis and then look at a
rival moral theory what we typically
call conscient deontological ethics
which appears to have nothing in common
with cost-benefit analysis in part
because Kant is often interpreted as
saying that consequences are of no
relevance whatsoever to the morality of
an action that is being done or
considered what matters most is whether
it's in accordance with Duty and the
motive by which the action is being done
but as Audi is going to argue it's not
quite so
clear cut as that and you know as a side
note if you think that really is the
case for Kant then you really ought to
read not just the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals and which can't
we'll talk about duties of beneficence
but also the other ethical works the
groundwork is merely an introduction to
the metaphysics of morals which includes
the metaphysical elements of justice and
the metaphysical elements of virtue Khan
has a number of other ethical works and
so a
well-read interpretation of Khan isn't
going to fall into that trap now that
doesn't yet mean that cost benefit
analysis as such is going to be
important from a conscient perspective
but Audi is going to argue that it
actually is and just as a bit of review
in case people aren't completely up on
their manual account so conscient ethics
um as he says is going to focus on an
overarching principle the categorical
imperative and he's got two different
names we usually call the
universalization and respect for
Humanity he's going to call them
universalizing Maxim formulation and
intrinsic end formulation so the first
one act as if the maximum of Your Action
were to become through your will a
universal law of nature he says I take
the explicit use of this to require
asking whether one can rationally very
important qualifier there
universalize one's Maxim so you can't
just say oh I'm cool with everybody
beating each other up all the time can
you actually rationally
universalize that and Audi points out
that in a certain respect this could be
seen as connected to the do on to others
you know Golden Rule if a thing is wrong
you cannot rationally will the principle
on which it is based to be Universal
because then you would think about how
it would be to come out on the short
side of the stick right which actually
seems to be considering consequences
doesn't it it's not exactly what Kant is
doing but it's close enough right
and he says that if we think about this
universalizing Maxim well that's going
to rule out breaking promises
particularly breaking promises on the
basis of a cost benefit analysis which a
utilitarian might be you know attracted
to doing if breaking the promise would
actually result in Greater utility
overall greater benefits over harms or
you know better consequences overall for
everybody concerned well then maybe you
break the promise and come and say no no
you can't break the promise because
you're violating uh you know morality by
doing so you can't universalize breaking
promises
um and so you know this this might be
one militating against it and then we
have the intrinsic end formulation act
in such a way that you always treat
Humanity whether in your own person or
in the person of any other never simply
as a means but always the same time as
an end and so he says that you know if
you think about obligations of
beneficence
obligations of beneficence obligations
to do good to other people
utilitarianism one of the problems with
it is it seemed to be saying you have to
maximize your beneficence towards other
people so like if you're rich you should
be using those riches to benefit other
people if you're poor okay maybe it's
time attention stuff like that rather
than money but you should always do the
most that you can
and from a conscient perspective I think
Audi is quite correct in this
if you were to do that you would be
treating yourself merely as a means
to other people's ends and so you
shouldn't do that you should in fact be
beneficent towards people right you
shouldn't just say screw everybody else
I'm not going to help anybody out
but you
ought to
you know have sort of limits on it so
that you're not exhausting all of your
own resources burning yourself out right
treating yourself as just a utility
maximizing thing rather than as a person
yourself right so
um this would also seem to militate
against cost-benefit analysis
so Audi says well
cost benefit analysis could be useful
because we're going to have conflicts
arising right
um there's going to be problems for
example deciding just what principles
governing the draft or the
permissibility of prayer in public
schools should be universalized and
govern all Humanity that's not that big
of a deal I think actually because we
could actually just think it through
using kant's categorical imperative but
what about conflicts between duties
says it what if we follow both
principles that require promise keeping
okay so that's one thing definitely in
line with universalizing
maxims and principles that require us to
render Aid when we can
also discussed by Kant in the groundwork
right and then we find ourselves having
to choose between keeping a promise to
do something for a
and helping bee who has just broken his
ankle right now we've already made the
promise in that case right so we're not
making a lying promise but we should
keep the promises that we've actually
made shouldn't we
and then he says how could cost benefit
analysis be relevant to these and he
says you might think that it's not
relevant at all to conscient ethics
right conscience conscionism is
deontological concerned with the
qualities of Acts it's not
consequentialist does not derive
rightness from goodness by providing a
teleological and you know a consequence
based Criterion of moral obligation but
he says this ignores the point that it's
there's no rational way to fulfill
duties of beneficence
um among others that are countenance by
conscient ethics without considering
consequences
of Alternatives right if you have
different ways of helping people out
then you should think about which one is
likely to lead to better outcomes or
less likely to have adverse side effect
consequences right which one is which
ones you can do most readily most easily
right this is pretty important and kind
of does think that you have duties of
beneficence so
conscient ethics is going to require us
to consider the Alternatives and he
points out another really interesting
thing as well
so
deontological ethics as opposed to
utilitarian ethics is saying listen
there's certain things you just can't do
and be a moral person right there are
certain things that are Outlaw outlawed
you could say from a moral perspective
that doesn't mean that people won't do
them but they're doing the wrong thing
and doing them likewise there are
certain things you have to do right so
how can cost benefit analysis take these
into account well Audi gives you a
suggestion here he says we can value
or this value the performance of a given
kind of Act Right of this sort of action
irrespective of its consequences so for
example if one option requires
performing a disloyal action we can
assign it a negative value on that
account alone we're not worried about
the consequences in that case although
we might also include those
we assign a value based on the kind of
action that it is
so you know this seems like it could
enter into the Matrix of cost benefit
analysis right
he says if something is absolutely
prohibited by morality then cost benefit
analysis would provide a mode of
peremptory veto of signing it
sufficiently high negative value an
infinite one in the limited case will
render it a alternative that won't be
chosen so that that looks like
um you know some compatibility there and
then he's got some really interesting
remarks about probabilities which play
an important role in cost benefit
analysis that he makes three key points
so one is kind of obvious right
probabilities are absolutely going to be
relevant to assessing consequences so if
we are going to take consequences into
account as you know fully blown
conscient deontological ethics does have
to do then he says alternative actions
um you know we have to look at how
they're going to work so if we're going
to be beneficent to people we have to
think about whether it's likely that the
course of action that we take is
actually going to produce good effects
right
so that's important but
he goes on further and he says
even the aspects or the kinds of actions
this is the stuff that's really germane
to conscient ethics even those
have probabilities at least in some
cases and so he gives an example saying
that if you promise to help A friend's
child your best attempt may or may not
actually constitute helping so we want
to think about probabilities in that I
mean how could that enter in well let's
say you don't know much about children
the probability of your efforts to help
them being successful are probably going
to be a bit low because you might make
mistakes in that
and then the third thing that he points
out about probabilities he says they may
be needed to represent epistemic
uncertainty as well as what we think of
as an unpredictability for example a
whistleblower may not be quite sure that
continuing on the job despite being the
loyal thing to do and making internal
rectification possible is acting
righteously overall so maybe we don't we
do want to assign probabilities within
some sort of you know Matrix of options
and all the costs and benefits or you
know the projected
um harms and and payoffs right now he
goes on and he concludes this uh part of
his his essay by saying to be sure
kant's emphasis on acts having moral
worth only if performed by Duty we might
infer that he intended consequences of
Acts to be irrelevant but this would
actually be unsound reasoning
kant's Insight is that what we ought to
do is one thing and whether we're
morally credit worthy for it doing it is
another and he gives an example of a
manager who having an employee's
performance record as a justification he
fires the person he does so from malice
well that's not doing it from Duty he
was just like I can't wait to fire that
SOB all right I got it here out of here
right that's not praiseworthy you would
have to do it because it's the right
thing to do and you realize that it's
the right thing to do and he's you know
he goes on and he says that the note
that the obligation of beneficence is
unintelligible apart from considering
consequences for the well-being of
would-be beneficiaries he does grant
that for Kant non-moral values will not
be the only or main relevant kind for
example protecting autonomy will be more
important than promoting happiness right
but that doesn't mean that happiness is
irrelevant to moral decision making and
so there is some scope some limited
scope we could say for a cost benefit
analysis even within the approach of
conscient deontological ethics